hey Russ I am doing some last-minute
adjustments for before I leave
got a schedule the videos uh uh-huh I
got a headache
I'm really tired the plane leaves in two
hours gonna have breakfast
why don't you come below yeah breakfast
they gave us biscuits for Edgar if you
want this again do you want this then in
a state you can do it come on show them
that you're good sick sick
hey God dick that game
alright I'm back I still got work to do
car is here in 30 minutes
god dammit there's few things that
stressed me out as airplanes I [ __ ] I
don't know what it is well we'll make it
somehow I'm sure everything is packed
there's a bunch of hidden treasures
there's my camcorder I'm really worried
because it's really expensive and this
is not how you do it I'm bringing my
microphone equipment it's somewhere here
think yep their day
please place oh man
when we moved to suite from from Sweden
to Italy I put my desktop there and it
actually made it either way I'm gonna
still record videos while I'm in LA so
that's why I'm bringing all this stuff
taxis actually here and we still I'm not
wearing socks I don't know yeah all
right I should stop logging
we're staying by it's the pugs what are
you doing to them Maya I'm gonna miss
you what
don't go proud of course Edgar
Riley he's so good
here's yes goodbye don't go boots please
please don't leave me Oh
we are now the vlogging couple
we're literally the last flight on the
list
Gate info in 1-2 hours I just ordered
pizza with Pierre on it I like have we
both said pair and up here yeah
how are you saying that wrong
how I hate filming food but this one I
have to film trying cuz it
because pizza we appear on it
please get alyc thank you
I mean it's not even a forehead right
now it's more like a nine head right
and there's no TVs
it's really hard
all right I don't want to show too much
but the game is amazing and I can't wait
for you bros to play but it's gonna come
out this month check it out
oh great we finally docked pity I look
so good I'm so tired
where's my luggage you see it
it's somewhere
should we just take someone else
that seems fair
yeah that's my chest
good
my hey so we you probably can't see me
we just got mom paparazzi style really
weird I can't believe that just happened
don't tweet out that you're going on a
trip before cool good to know it was
cool that but it was weird alright we
are riot at the house it's really nice
but we don't know how to enter so that's
good
the TV's on alright this is where we'll
be spending a month yes it's really nice
I really like it it's really cozy such a
long trip what I what a day
what a way to start what a shitty way to
start a daily vlog I have no idea how
this is gonna work out I don't I'm not
even sure if it will I am too lazy but
I'm gonna try and if you bros keep
showing your support likes and comments
and let me know if you enjoy it I will
definitely keep doing it I think it's
it's fun and it's a great it's gonna be
a crazy couple days and it be fun to
bring you brothers along with them so
this works out then I'll see you
tomorrow
and yes I'll I'll show what's going on
and [ __ ] alright I feel like we should
kiss
might say here no okay